autre sujet on prend à présent la
direction de la verrière le nouveau à
gina s'appelle official officiellement
pardon gymnase de la fraternité ont
choisi par les verriers roi lors d'un
vote plus de 460 personnes se sont
exprimées la ville l'a inauguré
officiellement ce samedi 3 septembre la
rénovation a duré un peu plus d'un an
pour un montant d'un million 3 financés
par l'anru des modifications à deux
salles ont été apportées écouter cette
précision reccueillis par mélanie poker
mais là c'est un peu vieillot déjà une
fois il correspondait plus trop ça
tangue des gens qu'il utilisait
en a profité pour
nouvelle salle
tel que l'a la musculation
un endroit que ça dit quoi tous
autonomes
il